hello everyone thanks for attending this
presentation today um i'm dr karen
woodall
i'm an assistant professor at the
university of toronto i work in the
forensic science department there
and i'm a forensic toxicologist and
prior to joining the university of
toronto i worked for 20 years at the
provincial uh toxicology forensic
laboratory
in the toxicology department
so today i'm going to be talking about
the opioid crisis and giving the
forensic toxicologists perspective
so i do know that there are a number of
different uh people attending this
presentation with uh different
backgrounds so i'm going to start off by
giving a bit of a overview about opioids
so
um
opioids are drugs that work on um opioid
receptors in the body
so originally opioids were natural
substances
for example they all arise from the
opium poppy and in the 1800s morphine
was first extracted from the opium poppy
and that was a major milestone in
pharmacology it was the first time the
active ingredient of a medicinal plant
was isolated
and morphine was named after the roman
god of dreams morpheus and that was due
to the
known effects of morphine at the time
which was based on its sleep inducing
and sedative properties
so we know that opioids are
widely used medications they're very
good for pain relief so they're widely
used for analgesia
however we also know that issues occur
to the high potential for abuse
we know that opioids can cause euphoria
which is one of the the major reasons
why they can be abused um and there's
also uh addiction issues so opioids can
be addictive
and opioids also can be very toxic
one of the main mechanisms of toxicity
for opioids is respiratory depression
which
sometimes can even lead to death
there's a number of different types of
opioids so as i mentioned traditionally
opioids like arose from the opium poppy
and the naturally occurring opioids are
all chemicals that um do arise from that
uh natural plant
so examples of these naturally occurring
opioids are morphine and codeine
there's also semi-synthetic opioids so
these are substances that are chemically
related to the naturally occurring
opioids but they've been slightly
altered
examples of these would be hydromorphone
and oxycodone
and then another type of opioid are
known as synthetic opioids
now these still act on opioid receptors
in the body however chemically they have
entirely different chemical structures
so they're chemically unrelated to the
naturally occurring opioids but they
still act on the same receptors
which brings me to what is the opioid
crisis
so the opioid crisis is the issue that
has arisen
based on the use of opioids
and the increase in desks deaths and
hospitalizations that have arisen based
on
opioid misuse
three waves have been identified
so the first one began in the 1990s
and was related to the use of
prescription opioids
an example of that would be the
widespread use of oxycodone
and back in the 1990s
it was believed that um use of these
prescription opioids
were not going to cause addiction
problems however that did not turn out
to be the case and we saw an increase in
abuse and increase in overdoses and also
an increase in death
the second wave occurred in
around 2010
and this was an increase in the
occurrence of heroin overdoses and
deaths
and one of the issues that occurs when
people can become addicted to opioids
if they can no longer get prescription
opioids then some individuals will turn
to other sources
to find their opioids
and then the third wave relates to the
use of synthetic opioids
mainly the use of fentanyl and compounds
related to fentanyl
known as fentanyl analogues
and then interestingly recently
some researchers have started to
identify
what's been described as a possible
fourth wave of the opioid crisis
and this involves poly substance abuse
so this is the use of opioids and other
drugs um usually stimulant drugs
methamphetamine and cocaine are the two
most common stimulants that have been
identified as being part of this fourth
wave
so this graph comes from uh ontario in
canada uh this is where i work um the
province of ontario has a population of
just under 15 million and so the data
that comes from ontario is useful for
monitoring trends in drug use
this information comes from ontario
public health
and they use information about opioids
that have been detected
in death investigations and they publish
this information um
uh on the internet and it's available
for
[Music]
anybody to access
you can see from this graph quite
clearly uh the the issue of fentanyl
and so this is relates to the third wave
of the opioid epidemic
and before
2015 um there weren't that many uh
fentanyl-related deaths in the province
of ontario but since that time the
number of deaths that occur where
fentanyl has been detected has increased
every single year
and
you can see that the last year where the
data is available so that's 2020 there
were over 2 000 deaths where fentanyl
was present at death
you find that these drug trends
are also seen in the us
so canada and the us
often you definitely see similar trends
in drug use and that is the same for the
opioid epidemic
so for example
in around 73 of all opioid-involved
deaths in 2019
were synthetic opioids this data comes
from the cdc
in
2019 so that's
that accounts for about 36 000 deaths
that all involved synthetic opioids
interestingly this data also shows that
uh the fentanyl which is the uh
main drug that's seen in these deaths
it's more likely to be from illicitly
manufactured uh fentanyl um compared to
pharmaceutical fentanyl and this shows
that the shift that's occurred in the
opioid crisis um if you remember the
first wave mainly involved prescription
opioids but now the shift has definitely
changed to more illicit opioids
so what's the role of a forensic
toxicologist
so a forensic toxicologist uh plays a
very important role
in
the opioid crisis
because the role of forensic
toxicologists and toxicology labs is
going to be
looking for
drugs so the different opioids in
various cases so for example in death
investigations
which opioids are present
you will also want to know kind of how
much drug is present so you can
interpret the findings so not every
opioid detected at death
means that it contributed to the death
and a toxicologist can assist with that
kind of interpretation is it a
concentration high enough to cause death
for example
toxicologists can help by doing research
into the toxicity of opioids
and then
collaboration between toxicology
laboratories with law enforcement
deaf investigators so including coroners
medical examiners and also public health
officials can be very important
so i mentioned the significance of
fentanyl in the third wave of the opioid
crisis so i'm just gonna do a little bit
of an overview on uh fentanyl and one of
the major
fentanyl analogues that seen in forensic
casework
so fentanyl is a fast-acting synthetic
opioid
it's a very strong drug so it's a
hundred times stronger than morphine and
morphine itself is a very uh powerful
opioid drug
it's used clinically to pre-medicate
prior to surgery
it's also available via prescription so
people are suffering from chronic pain
conditions may be prescribed fentanyl
pain patches
these are patches that can be worn on
the skin to give a constant pain relief
for up to three days at a time
and then fentanyl is available like
during hospital treatment and it's
usually in the form of an injectable
liquid
i did mention though how the shift of
opioid use during the opioid crisis has
moved away from prescription to more
illicit forms of drugs so fentanyl and
now
is found on the streets in terms of it's
often sold as powder
sometimes it's sold as heroin so drug
users may not be aware of the exact drug
that they're buying
this can be significant because heroin
is an opioid but it's not as strong as
fentanyl so if a drug user thinks
they're buying a less powerful
drug it may lead to an accidental
overdose
another way that fentanyl is available
is
through the use of counterfeit
pharmaceuticals
these are drugs that are designed to
look like
actual pharmaceutical medications and
however they are made illicitly and
don't contain the the drugs that people
think it does uh the picture on this
slide shows some green tablets that are
designed to look like oxycontin tablets
oxycontin contains oxycodone which is an
opioid drug
but again it's a drug that's not as
powerful as fentanyl and there has been
a large number of overdose
overdoses and deaths that are occurred
when people have been using these
counterfeit pharmaceuticals
not realizing what drugs they were
taking
and then fentanyl analogues are also
being detected in forensic casework and
fentanyl analogues are chemical
substances that are closely related to
fentanyl
the one of the most common fentanyl
analogues that seen in forensic casework
in terms of overdose deaths is a drug
called car fentanyl
carfentanil first appeared in um kind of
on the streets in canada in around 2016.
and this mirrors when uh it was first uh
first started to occur in the united
states as well
um carfentanil is an opioid drug um it's
approved for use uh
in large animals so some vets may use
carfentanil but it's never been approved
for use in humans
it's an extremely potent opioid
so it's a hundred times stronger than
fentanyl
and approximately 10 000 times stronger
than morphine so
if you recall fentanyl itself is an
extremely potent drug but now we're
looking at a drug that is a hundred
times
stronger than fentanyl
so another thing that's important
in the opioid crisis is something called
novel psychoactive substances
now the definition of that is that they
are they legally mimic the effects of
traditional drugs of abuse so for
example hallucinogens
stimulants
cannabinoids or opioids however they're
not internationally controlled so
legally they can be described as being
kind of in a gray area uh their soul
kind of over the internet
but in terms of uh the opioid class of
novel psychoactive substances and some
of the issues occur with this is that
these new substances uh they can appear
and then sometimes they can disappear
rapidly so in in certain countries or
part like
certain geographical reason regions uh
maybe for a few months you might detect
this novel a psychoactive opioid um it
might cause overdoses it might cause
fatalities and then a few months later
it seems to disappear and you don't see
it again in case work
other times a new drug will appear and
then it remains popular and you and you
see it
for more than a few months
so laboratories need to be able to adapt
quickly
this can be hard because a lot of
toxicology laboratories have limited
resources
so sometimes you need to make decisions
well which drugs are more prevalent is
this a
potent more toxic opioid is it something
that we need to develop a method for
rapidly
an example of that would be
carfentanil which i talked about earlier
so this research
i was involved in with some of my
colleagues from the center of forensic
sciences in ontario and and what this
research looked at was to provide
information on when car fentanyl
appeared in canada how did the
laboratory respond to the appearance of
car fentanyl so we looked at
adding carfentanil to one of the
common methods of analysis that we use
so we were able to start screening and
quantitating carfentanil in all the
routine death investigations
and that enabled us to
help the deaf investigators and provide
important information
for public health too to monitor this
new
dangerous drug and to see what trends
were happening and it's really important
for forensic toxicologists to share the
information they have with the
scientific and also the medical
community
one of the
things from this study was that we
looked at what other drugs were present
in deaths where
carfentanil was significant
we found that the most common
co-occurring substance in
carfentanil-related deaths was cocaine
and all benzoligonine which is a
breakdown product of cocaine
we found
the
indications of cocaine use in 54
of cases
this is similar to other published
research that also found stimulant use
with carfentanyl
so for example a study from florida
showed that cocaine was the most
frequently detected drug with
carfentanil
and a study from alberta in canada
showed that in that area it was
methamphetamine that was the most
frequently detected drug in combination
with
carfentanil and this type of information
adds to the
growing evidence about the potential
fourth wave of the opioid crisis
if you recall earlier i was talking
about people now saying that um opioid
use
it seems to be now occurring more
frequently with
um
stimulant drugs so this carfentanil
information
adds to this
fourth wave
i did mention about the novel
psychoactive substances and how they can
appear and then sometimes disappear
so carfentanil when it appeared in
canada it's still a significant opioid
it's still seen in many debt
investigations so it's it's frequently
observed in many forensic cases
other drugs so for example u47700
was a is a novel a psychoactive opioid
it appeared around the same time as
carfentanil in canada
and also in the us
users apparently report that they get
more euphoria taking you four seven
seven zero zero compared to fentanyl so
it was one of the reasons why uh it it
was becoming popular
it was a drug that was developed
by a pharmaceutical company
way back in the 1970s but it was never
used in humans so there was limited
information about the toxicity of this
substance
they did change the legal status in 2017
it became a scheduled one controlled
substance
and it hasn't um
it hasn't been frequently detected in
forensic casework
in canada
in recent years so this is one of those
examples where it was useful to be able
to detect this drug
however the trend for this particular
drug seems to be the the use has
declined
in terms of sharing information with
public health um the ability to forensic
toxicology labs to add a new opioid to
an analytical method
can be very important so it can provide
important surveillance information for
public health agencies
sometimes timely data collection and an
outbreak can have a significant impact
in supporting public policy and it can
allow kind of interventions
allow harm reduction
to be put into place to try and reduce
the dangerous overdoses or even deaths
that occur following opioid use
also
toxicology labs can help contin uh
contribute to research
for example about at-risk populations
an example of the role that forensic
toxicology can can play in this is um
drug alerts
so some organizations will work with
toxicology laboratories to enable rapid
drug testing of street drugs
an example of this would be in toronto
their drug checking service so this is
something where drug users can actually
send a small portion of their drug um to
a lab and they will test it and let them
know what is actually in in the drug
it's quite common that people buying
drugs illicitly they may think that
they're buying one substance it might
not be that substance or it could be cut
with other dangerous chemicals so it's a
way of reducing harm
for this drug checking service all the
results are monitored and then alerts
can be issued to the general public
so for example
in the spring of 2021 the toronto's drug
checking service issued an alert to let
potential drug users know that car
fentanyl was being detected in some
drugs that were being sold as fentanyl
because carfentanil is so much stronger
than fentanyl alerting users that the
drugs that they were buying might
actually be a lot stronger can sometimes
help reduce the risk of overdose because
they're going to be more careful
hopefully
if they're consuming those drugs so it
plays an important part in harm
reduction and can alert drug users about
potential contaminants
these types of early warning systems
they don't just come from testing the
illicit drug supply
you can get data from toxicology
laboratories information from
overdoses like hospitalizations
and you can alert law enforcement you
can alert public health and it can be a
crucial part in helping to deal with the
opioid crisis
so an example could be there could be a
certain
geographical area where a number of
deaths occur over a short period of time
and some of the toxicological data that
arises from that might be an indication
that a certain drugs are present in an
area so for example maybe carfentanil is
present and it's being sold as either
fentanyl or heroin and if people are
alerted to this
again it may help prevent overdoses
because they're aware that there's
something more dangerous in the drug
supply
toxicology data
is also important for general research
into
different areas of the opioid crisis
they can help look at drug trends they
can look at vulnerable populations
a couple of examples of that
this is an example
of a study that was looking at
opioid-related deaths in ontario during
the covid19 pandemic
so uh the
toxicology data and death investigation
data was looked at for the first 15
weeks of the pandemic
and it was found that there was a 38
increase in opioid related deaths
some of the trends that were seen with
these deaths were the individuals were
using drugs alone um outdoors in hotels
and motels
um during this time there was a lockdown
in ontario and people were advised that
they shouldn't leave their homes um
unless they had essential reasons uh for
doing so and so there was the
possibility that you know people were
less likely to deal uh to seek
assistance with
any drug problems they were having
they so they didn't access treatment
they maybe had reduced support network
so for example people using drugs alone
if they do overdose they don't have
anybody to assist them
so this was some useful information that
toxicology data helped contribute to
some research that i've been involved in
recently has been about opioid use in
correctional facilities
so we know from previous research that
inmates are particularly high risk for
opioid overdoses in comparison to the
general population and so we wanted to
look at drug related deaths in the
ontario prison system
to see you know how has the opioid
crisis impacted this vulnerable
population did we see trends that
mirrored the general population and
could some of this information be used
for potential harm reduction measures
one of the things that we did see so we
we looked at data from a death that are
occurred over a 10-year period from 2009
to 2019
and
um
it did mirror the general population in
terms of seeing a significant increase
in fentanyl-related deaths
which was
expected
and again it was useful information to
provide kind of public health people
working in correctional facilities
and some information that that's come
out of research like this
and some inquests that have occurred
into deaths that are occurred in these
facilities is to try and provide the use
of naloxone kits
in these facilities
naloxone or narcan is an antidote
to for opioid overdoses and it can be
extremely effective at um
uh uh saving lives uh reducing overdose
deaths and so having this kind of data
from uh research into opioids that are
seen during death
can help
they can help change
public policy
so just to conclude what i've been
talking about um i think that it's
important to note that in terms of the
opioid crisis uh collaboration it's
essential for helping to prevent
overdose deaths and just general
overdoses the opioid crisis has been a
significant health concern
and forensic toxicologists can help
provide timely data and also some
comprehensive surveillance
and it's hoped that this can help inform
efforts to prevent and respond to
various opioid overdoses
so thank you very much for listening uh
if you have any questions please feel
free to contact me
you can use my email address
karen.woodall at newtoronto.ca
i'd be happy to correspond and answer
any questions that you have
so thank you for listening